all right look i know you guys know the
deal by now it's three scary games we're
going to open up and we're going to do a
jump scare at some point i'm not happy
about it you're not happy about it i
know lexian isn't happy about it no
one's happy about it but it has to
happen we literally cannot go on with
the video until the jump scare happens
so we're just gonna get it out of the
way and then we can move on with our
lives okay all right everyone happy
everyone happy everyone happy
i just gotta wait for it
all right lexie and hit him
this is room before the dark
a very adorable game that probably isn't
scary at all
hi there i've been waiting for you to
wake up for hours can you help me with
something i really need your help
come talk to me oh
boy
hello i'm so hungry could you give me
something to eat i don't know if i can
i'm really in a mood for a cupcake right
now do you happen to have any i don't
know am i in my house
is this my
oh wow
look at all this
this is delightful
um
i guess i
grab a cupcake
you want a
cupcake thank you mmm tasty
i'm sure it is okay so i was really
bored when you were sleeping
i want to play
i need friends to play with do you have
any plush toys ah actually
i did just find this
i'm sure this is what you want
can you find me another one they
shouldn't play alone i'll do my best why
is this open
whatever
hi
shoes
[Music]
this raises some questions
oh hi
how delightful what about a duck would
you like a duck okay
um i don't see any other plush toys i
see some bricks or boxes i see a meat
cleaver
uh was there one in here um
[Music]
yeah i don't whoa what am i looking at
uh yeah i don't know if i do have any
other plush toys a salt shaker you could
play with i guess here
have this
okay never mind then oh door
[Music]
i found it
here you go i guess
oh what should i do with my new friends
i don't know play with them
do you have any markers anywhere we want
to draw something
uh
yeah i don't know about that i don't i
don't remember seeing any markers
anywhere oh wait ooh
hey this is
maybe a marker here
here you go
enjoy
thank you what is the door oh my god why
oh
it's getting kind of dark here somehow i
can't really see it the draw could you
give me a candle pretty please um
okay
[Music]
sure
yeah okay here you go
here you go
uh by any chance do you have some salt
i need salt for our art it seems a bit
like uh you're gonna do some kind of
demon summoning i've seen enough of this
to know that it might be bad and you're
gonna draw a pentagram or something i
need salt for our art
well there's that i guess that might not
be salt how about this
is the salt
oh you have a do you
by any chance of a cross somewhere
asking for no reason really
okay
funny look me in the eye look me in the
eye and tell me that you aren't going to
summon a demon or sacrifice me or do
anything unsavory or run towards in this
house which might not actually be mine
okay good enough all right promises have
been promised yours is you know just a
casual oh
here you go
i need some meat give us some meat
please oh good please
bonnie look me in the eye
and tell me that you're just hungry and
you're not gonna do anything unsavory or
untowards with the meat i am about to
give to you
i don't give my meat just to anybody
[Music]
is this where the blood orgy comes it's
very old
the last thing i need is a knife it
should be somewhere in the kitchen
you got it pal
knife ahoy
okay
here you go
oh
i've been waiting
oh my god for so long oh my god
and that's all there is
all done short sweet and to the point
they're coming for me next
are they i guess they'll get me at the
end of the episode where i will be jump
scared again when the giant bunny comes
to claim my life but for now
moving on
this is horror noodles
[Music]
you can see how scary the noodles are
i'm not sure
what horror noodles is all about
but we're gonna find out why did i pass
out again well guess i gotta eat
something that's the first thing i think
of when i pass out and don't remember
where i came from or where i've been
i gotta give me some noodles
well
all right
guess i better get some noodles
what is this water noodles egg sausages
spices
okey-dokey spices
all right let's get some water
seems to be broken i should check the
pipes downstairs
hi
that's
that's probably fine everyone has a
mannequin in their house
anyone seen a basement
anyone seen a basement around here ah
good
good great
oh no is this duct tape no cake
it's so quiet
but i hear something
good thing i have my flashlight with me
l to turn it on
oh yeah you back
oh yeah good thing
oh oh
[Music]
it seems to be locked why
oh
i'm coming after you mr roger
all right
everything seems to be a-okay
time to get me some noodles
i'm here for the sweet delicious nudes
well not nudes but noodles well i guess
better than nothing
water stove
oil
noodles did i do that right noodles yeah
eggs
who could it be at this late hour
yeah who could it be
hello
it seems to be locked yeah for good
reason oh
what
hello
peek-a-boo
why is everything so quiet in here i'm
going upstairs
who's up there oh
hope he goes away soon yeah i hope
hello is anybody dying
anybody being more adored
anybody being stabbed with a knife
anybody fine
okay goodbye
hi
who's there i'll kill you okay
interesting fascinating don't know why
that is all the way that that is but
it's not gonna stop me
i got sausages
i need spices spices there we go
do i have a bowl
bowl
bowl
stir
stir stir stir almost done
nice
i can enjoy these in bed i don't think i
can enjoy these in bed i think they're
done now now i can enjoy them in my bed
and go back to sleep
can i can i do that
i'm sorry
is this my bed
go to bed
what wait a minute is that it
is that it how is that it how the wha
what
huh all right i guess that's the end um
you know there's three scary games
sometimes you just get a one that really
is a brain scratcher not sure uh what
the deal is there but um
hey
still
not bad but i'm gonna go move on now
this game may potentially trigger
seizures for people with photosensitive
epilepsy if your discretion is advised
okay the parking lot
oh find your car ktu's car keys oh god
i see you where did i park my car
aha
hello
why so ominous
all right everything's totally fine
what was that i could swear it was there
yeah wait what
oh no
it's a parker and a parker lot of
terrors is everyone's worst nightmare
yeah
someone must be messing with me
come on now don't be ridiculous
oh
oh
oh okay who's there this is not funny
this is not funny
who's being unfunny now
oh hi oh wait hi
okay
all right what am i doing where am i
going what am i doing where am i going
why am i doing it i don't know what i'm
doing and i don't know why i'm doing it
what am i doing where am i going i'm in
here now hey oh boy the power must be
back on
what i should get the hell out of there
i gotta use the l elevator
[Music]
thank you
you think that you're so scary oh okay
all right yeah like you're gonna hit me
okay all right
all right little
disconcerting i would say
not what i would call terrifying that's
right get out of my way
get out of my way
hi town
i think i hear something oh hey oh whoa
hey
whoa okay better find another way down
um how why how so how do
i died
oh probably like a leftover flag if i
walk
okay fine okay and now i moved out of
the way and i'm not gonna go near that
car again
now i need to go somewhere else that i
can get the hell out of here because
that is my objective
sarah do i have a keys no
gotta be another way down right
definitely
okay i doubt there's gonna be anything
over here
yeah nothing over there what about that
big thing whatever that is
how about that
what is that
why is this here
how's this here
how's any of this here
hello ah
perfect
oh that's weird
um
is that what i think it is i don't know
what i think it is what is what i think
it is
oh
no
i fell into their trap
oh
no oh no
it could only end one way that was good
i liked that i enjoyed that it was
simple but effective
moving
on this is the speak from the abyss uh
this is a teaser or a demo of a game
that has a lot of really creepy stuff
going on wwe move forward alt-entered uh
get that if at any point you feel
overwhelmed press escape twice to close
the game
not me whoa
vanessa
it'll be okay uh vanessa given that this
is a horror game i have a funny feeling
that it is not going to be okay in my
experience usually this is the point
where things go absolutely unokay i'm
here for you again statements like that
reflect that i or you am about to die
because it's like a finality to it and
the irony would be that you'd be ripped
away from my arms at this juncture
interact
ah there goes the ripping away ring ring
ah no
it can't be that early already
ring ring a young woman vanessa rises
from her small futon on the floor she
begrudgingly looks at her phone 8 am
time to get up
[Music]
ow my head
i must have slept wrong my neck feels so
stiff
i can't believe i had that nightmare
again maybe it means something ugh five
more minutes ring ring ring ring yeah
yeah i know i need to meet cassie at the
rental shop last thing i want to deal
with after a move is the wrath of an
angry girlfriend
use andy to rotate z to strafe left c to
strafe right okie dokie
ah oh
i see
boxes so many boxes oh
[Music]
fascinating
guess cardboard boxes will have to work
until i get my desk from the old place
okay
i like it
i love limited movement things but
things that aren't inherently
frustrating this is fun that's why i
liked um inscription so much just the
movement was very fun snappy i don't
remember us having so much stuff i
should wait for cassie to get back
before unpacking
okay it is kind of flooded in here
something definitely feels off a strange
threatening aura can be felt in another
room
can it
why can't
oh i see the strange threatening aura
hey
whoa okay
hi
who are you
i'm so glad to see you showed up vanessa
who are you
my name is jermaine i'll be your
therapist for the evening i didn't think
therapists did house calls anymore if
that's what you call this this is a
special
one-time offer
on me so please indulge me miss rivera
hi telling me about your troubles before
we begin the therapy there are some
things we need to make clear
this experience is merely a
demonstration of the challenges you will
soon face
horrors you're about to witness might be
very different when you go through the
full journey you will have visions of
creatures far more terrifying than you
could imagine
this vision along with our main
appointment will contain plenty of body
horror
horrible and traumatic experiences and
exploration of a human psyche begging to
be healed please keep that in mind
before proceeding the abyss is a strange
and hostile world keep this in mind
young lady please step forward to begin
our session whenever you're ready
oh
before you go please no
time ain't gonna be for you okay uh
whoa okay do i just walk through you
okay i can't go that way all right well
i'll just scoot on by uh
weird
that's a little weird this oh that's
even weirder okay
interact
oh
where am i
the forest is filled with a gross odor
the trees pulsate and writhe vanessa
gags as she tries to get her bearings
back oh god i need to find my way out of
here fast do i
how
[Music]
what the hell is that the creature
twists and throbs
heart
kill the heart
no
oh what are you
hi
some demons will let you passing by
not all of us are looking for a fight
are you gonna let me pass by hi
ow ow ow this feels slightly erotic okay
cool good good cool good the heart
vanessa grips the heart in her hand and
pulls with a sickening snap the heart
comes loose and beats in her hand before
dissolving something in the distance is
opened
has it now
okay
goodbye
i see uh hi a coiled mask there's a
faint calming warmth it feels like it
could be useful later
does it
does anything in this place look like it
could be useful later
oh
good
great actually if you think about it
okay are you gonna pass me by
every door in this world is
alive the heart works like any other
body they keep the doors alive kill the
hearts kill the doors
i am uncomfy
i am uncomf
i am not comfortable
hi
i don't get why people always assume
demons are hostile have we not in this
small solace of suffering in peace have
you i don't know i have no idea i have a
funny
hi
hi
what are you looking at
you never seen a devil woman out on the
walk before look you look like a nice
girl so i'm gonna give you some advice
the demons here are about to get a lot
more hostile after that baptism all hell
will break loose
so unless you want your intestines torn
out i suggest you leave now
what baptism
you need to go back to places you've
been before maybe a door that was
previously closed is open maybe what are
you
where's that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you probably had that [ __ ] lake again
when is she going to get through her
thick skull that we're never getting
back into diss i'll see if that [ __ ]
swan suffers here forever
can i go through you
nope
okay i'm gonna go back to where i've
been before apparently all right
goodbye then i guess
oh god oh no i've broken it i've broken
it i broke it i broke it oh no there's
no way
how
how have i broken it already oh no what
where am i what happened
i'm outside the game guys i goofed i'm
outside the world oh no if i go forward
am i gonna fall no
okay
maybe i can get around all of this
get a behind-the-scenes look at
everything
here what the hell oh my god
i don't know why it's creepier that i'm
outside of this world normally breaking
a game usually just like i broke it look
at me but this one is more just like oh
god what have i done
this is very strange
oh what are you god your vagina mouth
why
why why
okay
i'm in i guess
hi
i made it
behold beyond this point lies the horrid
city of dis a vile civilization
inhabited by the cursed souls of who
lost their way in the abyss you're not
ready to enter am i not you don't know
that
you don't know that how do you know that
i'm going to the city of dis
try and stop me you cannot
how am i going wait
how did my direction get cattywumpus
my direction is literally now
caddywhumpus oh no i've become
caddywhumpust oh no
how do i do anything help help me help
me wait there's something in the
darkness over here i see something
i found something hello what is this
what are you oh where are you god i wish
i could see straight what are you
oh what are you the smell of rod is
stronger here than anywhere else in the
forest vanessa lurches forward hand
covering her mouth as she sees the vile
room before her a tall figure is coiled
into the walls the ceiling it was one
with the building a terrifying energy
exudes from it
what why
why does the terrifying energy exude
from it i wish i could see what the
terrifying energy was but i'm all
caddywhumpist why did i have to become
stuck outside the void and also
cattywompide
hello world mass
could be useful could be probably not
though hi what are you oh god what are
you
miss me what
well i'd be lying if i said i didn't
miss a friendly face i'm still trying to
figure out if you have a friendly face
i'll take what i can get why are you up
here anyway i saw you were uh walking up
here and i thought to myself this is
what i don't understand about humans
even though you're in a dangerous new
world even though you're just getting
yourself more and more lost you still
need to go around and poke your nose
where it doesn't [ __ ] belong far be
it for me to talk [ __ ] i admire your
drive girly gee thanks if you can get
past twins that's worth admiring in its
own right they're bad news best to avoid
them if you can help it why are you
telling me this he tried to kill me i
think honestly
you remind me of an old friend someone
who left me a long time ago obviously if
you've gotten this far you have the
drive to escape please
i think you would be much more enjoyable
when you're
stronger further down here you'll
encounter devil be careful if anyone
kill you
i want it to be me and i give what i
won't uh except for the fact that i
don't know if you're actually supposed
to be in the main path of content here
because i seem to be exploring areas
completely out of order from each other
oh what are you
oh
and not oh god it's skins from the
ceiling
oh and i honestly i don't know how much
this is like supposed to be here now or
is uh
supposed to be saved for later on when
the game's more done both could be
proper answers but i have a funny
feeling
just a funky feeling that i might be
seeing things that the developer may not
want to show or
i'm stupid and i've broken the game and
i've existed outside the realm of
reality and i'm just getting more and
more lost to the ebraco just like that
killer said the visuals of this game are
really really i mean gross but also very
cool like i appreciate it but also i'm
like oh
but also i'm like yeah i get it what it
evokes
is uh it's really unique and interesting
but also when i was a kitten i played
doom for the first time if you really
look closely at the sprites and the
walls of doom uh you see really horrific
things but when i first played it as a
kid i didn't see him because my brain
never even registered what those those
things were like bodies in the walls or
like things hanging from the ceiling
were bodies it never occurred to me that
those that that's what those were and so
it wasn't until i had played the game a
few times and had been down at a few
roads you know and was on a few replays
that i really started to look deeper and
this this evokes that sense of you know
the more you look the more horrific it
becomes and it does it does exactly that
look at the freaking faces on that thing
but this is very very cool even and
what's so interesting is like i'm not
even playing the game really right i'm
doing this completely broken i might be
seeing things that are not supposed to
be shown yet uh but i'm finding this
fascinating because i am just having a
great time seeing it like it's just like
it's a museum
maybe that's all demos really need to be
it's just like a little i always love
tech demos this is kind of like looking
at a tech demo in a weird way although
i'm being an [ __ ] and still playing
it but whatever even though i've broken
it
anyway
very cool ah man i really wanna i wanna
go back i wanna try that again just a
little bit you know i just wanna not get
stuck right
so i'm back in the forest
um before anything else was terrible i
go kill this heart
rip
yep that's normal
hello goodbye
uh
[Music]
this was coiled mass could be useful
whoosh
whoa hey it's you a man stands in your
way ah
it's you
we don't normally have a humans crawling
around the abyss
[Music]
look scared
we're not let me introduce myself i am
the man who will end your life the man
raises his knife he lunges forward knife
in hand what stops before cutting
vanessa
you totally [ __ ] fell for it
you just seen a look on your face oh my
god i have seen you from another
universe in another time in another
dimension
nothing you do can scare me
he's laughing alone at vanessa's expense
okay goodbye join
later
all right
did that open yes it did oh god
whoa
what are you
a visitor
is it vermin nay she is our guest of
honor
how disappointing
come now brother
do not act so cold what is wrapping
around your neck
humans are filth and vermin sister you
he must obey the idols here brother for
she is part of her on only ceremony
she's wicked incenses must be burned for
a blasphemous celebrations hey brother
you understand i will never understand
you this uh the human shall be divining
wrong in our righteous heretical
you should be honored young but i saw
you should be ashamed your flesh is
precious
okay look forward to ending your life
when the ceremony begins you will suffer
for all eternity just like the rest of
them okay
cool
it's a face
[Music]
uh later
hi
oh hello creature hangs from the ceiling
it's mouth mother's words but no sounds
escape looks like it's muttering baptism
you might be able to take the heart
attached to it i will
something is open in a distant place
great hi eyeballs
it is much worse seeing it from the
inside
oh boy
there's a door down there that might
lead a way out i think you can open it
by killing a heart in a frozen lake
beware though the devil who lives down
there is the organizer of this whole
baptism you're going to need a miracle
to get by if you just waltz on in
stranger things have happened in the
abyss
have they now i'm not sure they have
but they might have
who knows
hello hi
what are you
what are you i don't know
hello
good to see you
all right bye
okay bye
it's you again
all right
we've talked weirdly enough we have
talked okay bye
hello door
oh god it's the hanging skins
oh
hello smell of rot right vanessa's lunch
lurches forward hand covering her mouth
as she sees the vile room before a tall
figure yes one with the building
terrifying energy exudes
oh why do you gotta do that holiest of
holies our guest arrives early oh the
righteous baptism
come early we shall suspend our prayer
shall you
don't let me stop you holiness holy bob
let your flesh be washed with glory
[Music]
purge my mind purge my soul
[Music]
okay
vanessa what
vanessa don't be afraid
no matter what happened even if the
entire world turns against you i'll be
with you who who is with me
call my name
buddha what sophia
god that was weird i definitely did see
some things that i probably was not
supposed to see but even so very cool
very cool gross but you know sometimes
you know there there aren't a lot of
like body horror things out there it's a
genre of horror that does not get a lot
of love
in games i mean there's a lot of movie
body horror but lately it's more been
about the ooh spooky supernatural that's
fine i like that but honestly sometimes
just like this is just like it's cool to
see it's cool it's cool
very cool the only thing i'd say is i
hope they amp up like the sound work and
not like i like the result of the gross
like almost vomit-like sounds but it's
just like the rest of it i feel like the
world needs to you need to hear it a lot
more but other than that like i don't
want to give too much advice like
not a game developer so anyway that is
it for three scary games look i know
i know we know how this works i get that
i promote some things you go check them
out you cause you support me and then
there's a jump scare and boo it all gets
scary so i'm just gonna get it out of
the way you know podcasts distractible
go my favorite sports team tyler bob
wade all good people you want to listen
to that space with markiplier it was
very fun maybe go check it out again if
you want to if you haven't checked it
out i
god uh let's just get it over with oh
yeah
thank you and as always i'll see you in
the next one
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]